good morning believe nation today's
message is expect the unexpected
over you George Soros judge you've
written the second world war gave me a
lesson I've never forgotten what was the
lesson the main lesson that I learned
during the war is to expect the
unexpected in the situations that you
get into are so out of context with what
you have grown up with that you have to
examine the the framework in which you
you think and then you realize that we
all work with preconceived ideas and
those ideas don't necessarily correspond
to reality so there is this gap between
perception and reality and that's the
gap that I have really kind of explored
and also exploited after the war Soros
left Hungary and went to England to the
London School of Economics so they we
all grew up with a set of beliefs that
came from our parents our family our
friends and surroundings and a lot of
those helped us but a lot of them limit
us as well and so unless you want to
live a life that's exactly like the
people around you then you need to start
to question things question some of the
beliefs that you grew up with and
understand are these actually
representative of what you're about or
not this is where actually finding the
one word is really important having a
self-awareness to know what it is that
you stand for what the most important
thing is in your life and then building
around that both a business and life
that now has purpose and meaning instead
of accidentally having things randomly
happening you to help you now we're
sitting out to create a more powerful
course forward having it self awareness
really helps let's look at your beliefs
around money I don't think many people
grow up with a healthy belief around
money some people believe money is
everything all that matters is money and
some people believe that money is
root of all evil right money is negative
and you shouldn't do it if anybody goes
- money is greedy if you grew up
believing that money is evil and it's
greedy to ask for money then you never
charge what you're worth if you're an
entrepreneur one of the things that we
are terrible at in general is charging
wentworth most entrepreneurs should be
increasing their prices by at least 30%
based on the values they're actually
providing we undersell ourselves and
often that comes from a belief around
money or if you want to go and have the
impact that you want to have you want to
be able to build a team you want to be
able to help your community you want to
give back the causes you want to build a
real business you might have to charge
more but you'll never do it until you
fix your believer on money and so
understanding what your beliefs are
understanding the person that you
actually want to be right understanding
what your one word is and then seeing
the limiting beliefs that you have and
the positive ones that you want to use
to reinforce and build yourself up make
you get your difference this is your
blueprint and until you recognize it
until you out of it until you examine it
you're going to continue running the
same patterns over and over and over and
over and over again and no matter what
strategy somebody gives you you're never
going to really follow through on it
because the blueprint that you're
running is holding you back that's why
for a lot of these things the strategy
itself doesn't really matter like how to
go out and do this doesn't really matter
because you're not ready for it you're
still holding yourself back by the same
story that you've been telling yourself
your whole life those sets of limiting
beliefs will continue to hold you back
until you break through them and then
you'll be ready to hear the strategy and
tactics to move forward so the question
aka is I'm curious what's the biggest
limiting belief that you have that you
have recognized and are trying to break
through or have recently broken through
on leave it on the comments below
signatures to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Joe doe Donny
Joe thank you so much for picking up a
couple of my book you're one word it
really means a lot to me Joe I hope you
enjoying the read and that it's about
value to your business and your life
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
so keep me go